the Joe Rogan experience are there
anything is there anything you can do in
terms of how you eat or supplements you
can take that could potentially at least
somewhat mitigate the effects of having
no sleep we haven't found any good
countermeasures have you tried diet
pills so people have tried things like
acid rain they fell Amin FS amines
you know I mean caffeine has been used
strategically by the military for years
and caffeine can help you get over the
basic reduction in your alertness so
basic response times mhm you can you can
dose with caffeine and still maintain
some degree of a fast response under
conditions of sleep deprivation
what about provigil or new vigil you
study yes a modafinil yeah is sort of
the underlying chemical there and it's
debated who actually came up with it may
have been the French military who
actually ended up being the generators
of that that seems to work through a
pathway at least right now as we
understand it for a chemical called
dopamine and dopamine is principally
known as pleasure drug it's the chemical
that a lot of drugs of abuse will target
to sort of ramp up but it also is a
basic alertness drug that when you get
an increase in dopamine you tend to
actually get an increase in your
alertness and your wakefulness don't you
get an increase in happiness as well you
can - although modafinil tends to come
with the alertness component of that
equation and less so with the euphoria
that's why it has a lower prevalence of
sort of addiction and abuse boy I know a
lot of people who I wouldn't say they
abuse it but they say they have to use
it like all the doctor says doctor cells
are gonna use it and I'm always
suspicious cuz they seem pretty normal
other than the fact that they they're
exhausted if they don't take this what's
essentially stimulant I've taken it a
few times I've taken it when I have to
drive like long periods of time like I'm
driving from San Diego to California or
to Los Angeles and maybe I have a gig my
gigs done at like 11:30 I know I'm gonna
be on the road late at night I might
take one and it's fine but it gives you
this weird feeling it's a weird state
and I know all
lot of tech people yeah a lot of Silicon
Valley is on this stuff and they pop it
like candy so much so that Tim Ferriss
when he was writing his book the 4-hour
body he didn't want to include it
anyone include this particular drug
because he felt like people were just
gonna eat it all the time yeah I mean
and it's right throughout student
populations yes if you cook as well as
adderall yeah yeah and I draw you know
I'm one of the interesting things is
that if you look at the the profile of
what sleep deprivation is cognitively
you know reduced alertness impulsivity
lack of ability to concentrate
difficulties with learning and memory
difficulties with behavioral problems if
I were to describe those features to a
pediatrician and say what disorder is
this probably say it's it's ADHD yes but
what we now know is that there is some
portion of children out there who are
diagnosed with ADHD who either one or
just under slept or to actually have
sleep disordered breathing because of
perhaps tonsil problems where they're
not getting sufficient sleep and when
you treat the sleep disorder when you do
a sort of you know remove the tonsils
they start sleeping normally and the
ADHD disappears Wow so there is an issue
here I think within that sort of the
explosion of ADHD not all people are you
know sort of privy to this sort of sleep
problems simply masquerading as ADHD but
some people are the one of the other
problems too though is that ADHD kids
tend not to sleep very well and what we
end up giving them is a drug that is a
stimulant which will combat sleep and
fight back against sleep so I think we
need to have a bit more of a strategic
approach as to when we think about at
least the dose of those that medication
in terms of when sleep should be X sort
of expected during the day because you
know taking it in the middle of the day
in the evening and if it's stimulants
it's a wake promoting drug needs to be
very careful the sleep is part of that
it was that's terrifying because I don't
know if the people that are prescribing
these things have this sort of deep
education and sleep and the necessity of
it that you do they don't and you know
it's not their fault either you know and
in fact I've started to try and Lobby
doctors to start prescribing sleep and
don't make the mistake that that's me
suggesting you know prescribing sleeping
pills that's a separate story sleeping
pills are associated with significantly
higher risk of death and cancer and I'm
happy to speak about that too
[Applause]